I'd like to play a clip of one of your
famous exchanges with Anthony fouchi
from July 2021 where you're asking him
to correct the record after he denied
the government ever funded gain a
function research let's roll
that Dr fouchy knowing that it is a
crime to lie to Congress do you wish to
retract your statement of May 11th where
you claimed that the NIH never funded
gain of function research in Wuhan
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement this paper that you were
referring to was judged by qualified
staff up and down the chain as not being
gain of function what was let me finish
you take an animal virus and you
increase his transability to humans
you're saying that's not gain of
function that is correct and and senator
Paul you do not know what you are
talking about quite frankly and I want
to say that officially you do not know
what you are talking
about what are your Reflections on that
knowing what you know
now well it's a great clip in the in the
sense that his response is that his
experts at the NIH have judged this up
and down the chain have judged this not
to be gain of function research well
this is very intriguing so what we have
been requesting for two years is the
discussion if his scientists discussed
and debated and concluded did that this
was not gain of function research let us
see the deliberations so one of two
things are possible either he's
overstating the case and the
deliberations never took place or the
deliberations took place and aren't
quite as clear-cut as he's making it and
so far the NIH has refused to reveal any
of these documents so these are not
classified documents but still the NIH
is more secretive at this point than the
CIA we can't get NIH documents or HHS
documents we get uh there are several
different articles or descriptions of
discussions that we want we have the
name of them they send it to us and
it'll be 250 pages long all redacted so
it's making it impossible for us to
assess the truth to have oversight but
it's also impossible for us to fix the
problem if they don't let us examine
what happened this time around yeah you
know there was a redacted email that uh
really made me start to consider the
level of deception that might be at play
here it was this February 2020 email
that voui sent you'll see it there on
the left side of the screen the redacted
version and the house committee uh was
able to get it uh unredacted and if you
zoom in on this highlighted portion of
the unredacted email this was with his
kind of inner circle of scientists
talking about this phone call where they
all agreed they were concerned early on
that this was a lab leak and uh that
concerned was heightened by the fact
they say that scientists in Wuhan
University are known to have been
working on gain of function experiments
and kind of further research has found
these uh the uh papers like this one uh
this 2017 paper discovery of a rich pool
of bat SARS related Corona viruses uh
this was a collaboration between the
Wuhan lab and Peter Deek Eco Health
Alliance and was funded by an NIH Grant
and the you know the highlights here
just show that uh basically they created
a bunch of Art icial viruses by
combining eight different P bat SARS uh
Corona viruses with the wi one uh
backbone and then those viruses
replicated efficiently in human cells so
I I guess the the question I have there
is it it's clear in your book that you
believe there's likely a level of
deception here if that proves to be true
what sort of consequences should there
be you you know it's a crime it's a
felony to lie to Congress it's
punishable to up to 5 years in prison
after we determin that fouchy did lie to
Congress that indeed he had funded gain
of function research we submitted the
evidence to uh the Attorney General to
meric Garland but unfortunately he's not
done anything with it a year later when
more evidence accured we referred him
again for criminal prosecution and yet
nothing has done but the thing is is
that everything that he's saying there
in private in that email he's basically
admitting it was gain a function he
knows that they funded it he knows that
the the virus looks manipulated and yet
at the same time he was saying that this
is essentially February 1st of 2020 four
days later he commissions a an article
to be written in a journal by his
cohorts one of the main ones was
Christian
Anderson in private Christian Anderson
is saying this is not a conspiracy
theory this is not a fringe theory in
fact it may be the most likely theory
that the virus came came from a lab in
the paper that they publish at Anthony
fouchy behest they say explicitly that a
lab constructed virus is not a plausible
idea at all not even plausible not
really to them virtually possible they
in fact conclude in the abstract of that
paper that covid is not a laboratory
construct not that it probably isn't it
is not a laboratory construct meanwhile
saying privately they think it's most
likely we have several of these
scientists saying I'm 80 20 80% lab 20%
nature you know 5050 some of them are
saying meanwhile in public they're
they're acting with shy they're acting
with complete confidence but really what
they're doing is issuing a a nothing to
see here notice it's a it's a cover your
ass basically they don't want people to
draw the linkage because they know
they're responsible for funding This
research and that ultimately culpability
for the pandemic will attach to them so
it is a huge coverup not just Anthony
fouchy but throughout government eight
different Departments of government were
funding this type of research and that's
just the non-classified we think there's
still more to be found one of the
research papers that was leaked by a
whistleblower is from 2018 where Dr shei
from Wuhan Dr Barrett from UNC and Dr
Peter daac for Eco Health were asking
for money and they wanted to take a
Corona virus and insert a special
cleavage site into it that makes it more
infectious than humans it's called a
furin cleav site well that one didn't
get funded but that's exactly what Co is
is a Corona virus with a a human
cleavage site in it that's never been
before seen in nature and yet when they
saw covid you'd think if you were one of
the people on that Grant you would have
immediately called Anthony fouchi and
said holy cow this new virus has the
same sequence as the same graph they
were looking for in 2018 that we were
going to help them with beware this is
more evidence and yet nobody told uh the
public list if they told Anthony F he
suppressed it and we only found out
about it not from records releases but
from a whistleblower who actually came
forward and gave us this information
this is the real problem there's this
enormous coverup within government and
we still have to have the information
come out because Democrats still need to
be convinced that there is a problem
that we need to do something about gain
of function research to try to prevent
this kind of accident from happening
again hey thanks for watching that clip
from my conversation with Rand Paul you
can watch another clip right here or the
full conversation over here